if you listen to to Marx he talked about
new socialist man that normal that the
man that man is not ready for the
Socialist uh system
you have to remake man Nietzsche did the
same thing when he talked about the Uber
the Uber match the over man he believed
that without God man had to come up with
his own new morality and normal man us
would not understand
the over man's morality and the over man
isn't in any position or isn't obligated
to explain to us what they're trying to
do is nothing new like the idea that we
can reshape the world to prevent climate
change which I I mean there's a lot of
things that I have problems that I have
with the arguments for climate change
um but
the effort to remake Humanity always
ends with piles of dead bodies